your accent reminds me of home I always
live what I run into you like it just
feels so where did you grow up I grew up
in North Carolina my mom made me be a
debutante that's how slow you're a
southern belle you're a southern belle
wait what did that entail what did you
have to do oh my gosh you are so fancy
right now y'all had to wear white oh my
god you were from like the bricks I was
from the sticks girl we didn't have
anything like that soon yeah but we had
no money I that was the thing my mom had
been one and then we lost all our money
gambling she still wanted me to carry on
this tradition of being uh pretending to
be rich and they go to etiquette classes
I don't have my face with a napkin and
you know you can't wipe your face like a
monster obviously I didn't attend I
still to this day people are like you
should never eat in public so what did
your family think whenever you told them
they're gay cuz forming from the South
that is not always an easy conversation
yeah I mean III think my mom for her she
just like she don't want my life to be
harder than then what life can be you
know already already but you know we
have this really poignant moment I
talked about it in my special where I
told her I was gay and she was like
stone-faced and I was like oh man does
she like hate me now and she was like we
are going to Hooters
[Laughter]
that was her light of being like I
accept you
let's go to he told my dad he was like
you know he's a very typical southern
man is very simple and he's like okay
alright well you also buy you a men's
blazer top hat top hat he's mine like
I'm like minion you want to dress like a
man like okay let's get you that top hat
blazer I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this